Carlos es el administrador de un sitio de
internet muy grande.
Este sitio requiere de servidores web y servidores
para bases de datos.
Cada servidor web tiene un costo de 40 dólares por mes,
mientras que cada servidor para bases de datos
tiene un costo de 60 dólares por mes.
Para tener una idea del costo mensual total
que pagará la compañía,
Carlos hizo la siguiente tabla.
Aquí podemos ver en la tabla, la cantidad
de servidores web,
la cantidad de servidores para bases de datos,
así como el costo mensual total.
Él calcula que si se necesita un servidor
web y éste tiene un costo mensual de 40,
puedes multiplicar a 40 por 1 más la suma
del costo de un servidor de bases de datos
que es 60 por la cantidad de ellos, 60 por 1,
así lo podemos ver en diferentes ejemplos,
tal vez aquí 3 servidores por 40 dólares,
3 por 40, más un servidor para bases de datos,
que tiene un costo mensual de 60 y así, a
nosotros nos están pidiendo
¿cuál es la expresión que describe el costo total mensual para "n" servidores web?
"n" serán los servidores web y "m"
servidores para bases de datos
Tomaremos "m" como la representante
para los servidores,
la cantidad de servidores para
bases de datos que utilizaremos.
Y entones nos preguntan, ¿la expresión para
el costo total mensual en dólares será?
Para ello lo que haremos es multiplicar el
costo que tenemos de los servidores web,
que será 40 por "n" dado que estamos tomando
a "n" como la cantidad de servidores web,
"40n" más 60 que es la constante que tenemos
que es el costo mensual por cada uno de los
servidores para bases de datos, 60 por "m",
donde "m" significa la cantidad de servidores
para bases de datos que estamos ocupando.
De tal manera que nuestra expresión quedaría
"40n" más "60m".
Y para ello vamos a tomar el siguiente ejemplo.
¿Qué pasa si nosotros tenemos 20 servidores web?
Pues 20 será "n" entonces tomaremos 40 por
20 más 10 servidores para bases de datos,
60 por "m", 60 por 10, que de hecho aquí
lo tenemos, 40 que es el costo por "n",
20 en este caso, más 60 que es el costo mensual
por "m", "m" en este caso es 10
y con esto tendremos el costo mensual
total que pagará esta compañía,
para tener funcionando adecuadamente
su sitio de internet.